amico mio grazie prego ma poi mi
chiedevo montatore internet ma
vediamo quanto bravo anche in questo
pazzesco ed aimag amico incredibile ti
voglio bene anche grazie buon work
meraviglioso e quindi ragazzi
risvegliati dal tuffo olimpio
salve allora vediamo se riesco sborsato
fin lì a
poco vedo che a saltelli non sto messo
benissimo però vabbè non importa o fare
un po di climbing non so bene dove sto
andando era che effettivamente però da
quando sono caduto non vedo niente
perché l'hanno tolta la torcia quale
cosa ce l'hanno contro le torce sti qua
però la me perché non me la posso tenere
dall'inizio del gioco non si vede una
sega
salve un po di vino rotto ha guardato
che siano va bene cioè tutto sto
bordello
no sono tornato dove all'inizio del
gioco sto male
c'è tutto sto portello perché la si è
tornati qua ma come me ne valgono me ne
vado ciao arrivederci
cosa
c'è una zattera che volteggia
ei
mi sembri vedere leonardo di caprio in
lontananza che è affogato proposta che
si storia ci ha fatto tornare indietro
sta cosa assurda
e se invece salgono i quadri che cazzo è
che cos'è successo
stufi chiede tutta sta la chiave 2 la
uso
dove la voce l'amica la pole non ho mai
visto porte chiuse qua non so dove
dovrebbe poter utilizzare una chiave
però va bene
e quindi
a laporta lab la gabbia nell'inizio che
va bene perché salto
yes yes sono tornato non c'è più lo zio
di che è una positività non indifferente
prima di qua perché la stoffa c'era lo
zio quindi nel dubbio
perfetto ho sbagliato già subito la via
è leon i'd rather
calata l'hai tu ma
non è tutto a posto e non è così
favola santo iddio
dovevano riquadri qua
[Musica]
quanta gente del fuoco aiuto
ma ha ficcato 220 cazzotti 2 vado bene
sopra ceti gente sotto c'è gente che
devo fare gol
è stanco non può correre mio personaggio
che è perfetto la porta a porta fino a
porta una volta
merda sono andato perché ringrazia legno
posso togliere questi piloti togli
cristo
minchia che ansia
salvando tutta punta cioè per niente
tutto al fuoco a ottimo e non in tutto
questo continuano a vedere niente
pensate nel cast di sfiga va dove sotto
nei tubi
mi mancava sapeva bene
siamo usciti non solo nella fattispecie
dove siamo finiti ma chi se ne frega
c'è un ponte
possa andare là sotto secondo voi come
no
posso fare parkour finché non arriva
dall'altra parte del ponte proviamo
ok
ok neanche troppo male ragazzi mammamia
vuota pro gamer of a tutta la sponda un
fenomeno ma me la sto parlando è per
essere
sono ancora morto nicchia sto andando a
finire ragazza mi sta facendo tutto sto
posto c'è gente crocifissa sempre più
allegro comunque vedo male di qua
mancio ciao ragazzi tutto a posto spero
di sì dai non è proprio un albero
spettacolo per uno che si sveglia che si
affaccia alla finestra probo fate cas
che volete che tutto questo casino a
cosa cacchio servito dalle
targhe
ma [ __ ] una squadra che non
possiamo tornare indietro e tutto sto
casino dove vado
a posso schivarlo
mannaggia è
stato fortuito stronzo ayat
basma e calcio sto andandoci questo
quando spara un metro e aiap fang all
aero duca es
e sparito
conveniva più a me sparire calliari e
quello del no fucile e che si è messo il
66 messa e s'è ficcato da un'altra parte
io sono morto e ve lo dico
perché non lo posso più schivare non ci
sono roba che climber è stato bello
vacca [ __ ] cagato nelle mutande
ancora ma che palle questo
va bene fai te che cazzo sei
mangiamorte come fai trasportati da una
parte all'altra eh sì tanto dopo aver
preso il calcio tutto è andato sfocando
si è iniziato a strozzati col tuo sangue
ben sa sono svenuto mentre mi trascinava
sulle rotaie che dopo che ripreso
conoscenza se i nudo qualcuno ha curato
le tue ferite e c'è una nota sul muro
sono nudo vorrei dei vestiti
da leggera lattine che pesaro nudo
chi è che ha curato le mie ferite colom
ha sparato sto stronzo eccole santoni ha
tra l'altro per forza che come ho fatto
come hanno fatto a curarmi che mi ha
sparato tre volte e vabbè
cazzo di potere perché mimì
tramortiscono poi mi fanno andare via
sono pazzi poi al vostro obiettivo coppa
temi se vi dovete avere la
cruz
sembra portato in cima proprio
ringraziando a cristo siamo noi ce
l'hanno ton sul muro non l'ho letta è
certo figure
così
potevo fare a tema
mi sa un po di boss fight suo posto però
potrei anche sbagliarmi
vedo niente
giorno
eccolo lo zio senti tanto se volevo
uccidermi poter incidere di prima a sto
punto facciamo con questo punto
chiacchieriamo dica
tu il vino grazie all'ospitalità 6
gentile 6 anche molto bravo a ruotare su
se stessa senza motore le gambe io
vorrei capire cosa ci faccio qui è una
boss fight ci dobbiamo aiutare volevi un
incontro vero per come ucciso senti
dimmi se sei un uomo vero un pistolero
stato bello di lui tutto questo era lì
ferma a guardarvi sono sceso ok cacchio
vado ma al 18 qua perfetto che avrebbe
spaccato il ginocchio di sempre
molto bene è molto molto bene un cazzo
ayala fango era un vedo non sento e mi
fai male sono stanco già si conoscono
stanco non corrono core
perché questo deve essere stanco dopo
metro manco mi nonno è stanco dopo me
come cazzo corri
il casinò infinito vi prego basta
negozi chiusi
dove cacchio siamo ad ora che che
quante cose stanno succedendo
di sangue va beh a salve
molto me la lego rispetto a prima come
mai
che succede
le serre large lg complete mi chiede se
la sogas
c'è bordello rega mamma mia
maran luca due ore sono stato 2 ci ho
messo una vita a fare sta preparare i
poteri sia finita vediamo lo zio
si respira al peso
la lanterna l'ho buttata perché non ce
l'ha più lo zio lo sento
sta piovendo vino
mi sono stancato perché ho fatto i miei
consueti 10 metri ok
a
fool en open bottom line up e chi sono
questi
i capitani sono pagato
io ero qua solo per portarmi via la
bottiglia di vino integra per fare per
capire che cosa era successo però mai
sparato potevi farlo un'ora prima
ma proprio anche all'inizio del gioco
diva non ho capito è che ci stai
aspettato tutto sto casino per cosa ma
mi curie di nuovo
9 gira fischietta
la donna
li porti di nuovo mi curi iniziato tutto
sto bordello per morto pure a tanto
[Musica]
oro per il no a several years later ok
diversi anni dopo
quindi cosa è servito tutto sto bordello
spiega che cosa
a cosa è servito di uccidermi subito e
trascinato ma è curato con chi sono i
dati non sono morto al paradiso bello
gobbe com oppure posso andare avanti
a posso lasciare una lettera la tomba la
lettera la somma
non puoi andare c'è una tomba qua
di essere sepolto io qua posto
incredibile
la porta è chiusa si apra l'altra faccia
una tomba è alle spalle e ci abito
ancora la città comunque tutto questo
marty bernello
e la la città minchia la vedo ancora
sono morto là dentro il frigo
martifer mello
ha il figlio picchia
alla figlia non figlio
ma che roba
la figlia è andata a portare il
bellissimo dove si veda ancora città
mamma mia oro james ago quante case di
stato dobbiamo fare sto gioco ma
spiegamento
madonna che storia va bene ragazzi
questo era four c'è il primo che ci sono
anche altri che stanno per uscire spero
che vi sia piaciuto però che la miseria
che comunque alla fine è uscita la
miniserie come al solito servizio è
piaciuto e mi piace anche per il sociale
che mi ha detto descrizione c'è ma se
avessi schiena e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video della ragazzi
[Musica]